la situation de l'énergie dans l'Union
européenne elle n'était pas bonne
puisque au début de la crise nous
importions 64% de notre énergie de
l'extérieur notamment l'Allemagne qui
dépendait à 80% du gaz russe donc en
fait il y a une inflation des prix une
raréfaction de la matière donc au niveau
de l'énergie a fallu au niveau européen
trouvé deux solutions en garantissant
l'approvisionnement en énergie pour tous
les Européens et en travaillant sur les
prix donc les prix soient maintenus à
niveau le plus bas possible l'avenir de
l'Union européenne s'est renfossé
l'autonomie stratégique énergétique qui
va nous permettre en fait de moins
dépendre des importations donc dans ce
cadre là il faut développer tout ce qui
peut être produit en Europe c'est à dire
les énergies renouvelables qui sont
forcément pas délocalisables puisque
l'énergie verte on va la produire ici
dans l'Union européenne comme c'est une
énergie intermittente il faut derrière
des moyens pilotables c'est à dire que
quand il y a pas de soleil ou quoi il y
a pas de vent il faut quand même que
l'électricité soit là pour éclairer pour
chauffer les gens donc à ce moment et
bien il faut du pilotable derrière c'est
à dire d'énergie hydraulique par exemple
mais également de l'énergie nucléaire
qui est totalement décarbonée et comme
le but de l'Union européenne c'est
d'arriver à la neutralité carbone en
2050 et bien il faut profiter en fait de
cette crise pour faire des efforts pour
notre environnement et pour les
générations futures nous travaillons sur
la directive red reliewebel énergie
la fameuse directive des énergies
renouvelables qui va nous permettre
d'accélérer l'installation d'éoliennes
mais également de panneaux
photovoltaïques de nouvelles générations
fabriqués en Europe cette fois-ci mais
également les énergies marines et en
énergie osmotiques un certain nombre
d'énergie moins connues mais qui sont
très neutres pour le climat dans l'Union
européenne une quinzaine de pays
souhaitent avoir recours à l'énergie
nucléaire en complément des
renouvelables donc il faut les aider
avec un cadre européen qui permet de d'y
arriver et on essaie ensemble d'avoir
une reconnaissance en fait de du
nucléaire à travers
la mobilisation de son privé c'est la
taxonomie à travers la directive pour
les êtres d'État qui va permettre aux
états de financer cette énergie propre
dont on a absolument besoin si on veut
atteindre la décarbonation en 2050